[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily if
somebody's outside of a vehicle and
there's a bench warrant for weapons
violation and if he tries to flee
you can use force to stop him correct
reasonable force yes the prosecution and
defense argue x-cop kim potter's use of
force was it justified and i blame larry
nassar
and i also blame
an entire system
that enabled and
perpetrated his abuse a settlement is
reached bringing some closure to
survivors of larry nassar's abuse plus
will former white house chief of staff
mark meadows face criminal contempt
charges do we have lords and nobles and
friends of presidents who don't have to
respond to congressional subpoenas or
court subpoenas if they don't want to
uh
it is not up to individuals and later
did derek chovan allude to a future
change of plea there's going to be some
other information
in the future that would be of interest
what we expect to see when the
ex-officer appears in federal court law
on crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin day five of minnesota versus kim
potter began with a win for the defense
as judge regina chu shot down two
motions by the state requesting the
defense not be allowed to elicit expert
testimony from law enforcement witnesses
as the legality of potter's conduct this
comes after startling testimony officer
michael johnson made on friday
and if he had taken off with you
in that car halfway what would have
happened to you
do you what would you think would be the
worst that would happen probably dragged
and what
injured seriously injured maybe even
dead right yes
and if that were the case
with an officer in your position with
kim
officer potter
trying to stop him from resisting with
you and resisting lucky would it be fair
for that officer to use a firearm to
stop him by state statute yes
potter an ex-minnesota cop faced his
manslaughter charges in the shooting
death of dante wright stemming from a
traffic stop in april of this year
officers say they pulled right over for
unregistered tags at the time wright
called his mother and told her he was
being pulled over for an air freshener
hanging from his rear view mirror
officers say they attempted to take
right into custody after determining he
had a warrant out for a gross
misdemeanor weapons charge body camera
footage caught the incident on video it
shows a struggle between wright and the
officers before potter shot right in the
chest as he got back into his car wright
died as a result of his injuries potter
says she accidentally grabbed her gun
instead of her taser on tuesday the
prosecution called to the stand
commissioner garrett fleshland who acted
as potter's supervisor at the time of
the shooting he told jurors about
department policies and read excerpts
from the department's handbook
why is it that this unnecessary force
language or abuse is right in the code
of ethics
force is significant if we use
and we don't want to use unnecessary
force
in the next line it talks about the
badge of my office as a symbol of public
faith
how do you see that fitting in that
language with your role as a police
officer
i think police officers have an
incredibly important role in society
there's statutory uh requirements or
statutory limitations but uh i think
there is a a very special social
contract that exists between police
officers in the community
police officers are extremely forward
facing
arm of the government
and
it's a special
special role and relationship we have
with
with society
you're wearing your badge today correct
yes
what does it mean when you put that
badge on in the morning to you
it's it's a reminder that it was given
to me by the public to
to go serve and protect
this week the jury also heard from
expert sam mcginnis an agent from the
bureau of criminal apprehension mcginnis
told jurors the differences between a
glock pistol and a taser while the
prosecution made the weight difference
between the weapons the center of the
argument the defense highlighted the
similarities
and when you weighed the firearm what
was included in that weight
ammunition
17 rounds of live ammunition correct
and why did you weigh the firearm with
ammo
that would represent
what was in the firearm the day of the
incident
and did you uh
you weighed both items correct correct
did you document the weights of those
items yes okay what were the results the
firearm weighed approximately 2.11
pounds
the taser weighed approximately 0.94
pounds
the taser 7 or the tasers in general
have a handle
that is similar to a gun correct
there are differences of course
but it's designed so you hold it in your
hand right correct
it's designed so that you pull a trigger
like a gun right they both have triggers
yes and it's designed so you aim at
somebody right yes
joining us today is former federal
prosecutor gene rossi and terry austin
gene testimony today focused on police
policies how are both sides using their
this to their advantage
absolutely and i think the defense is
doing a better job the prosecutors
having the officer
or the commissioner testify about you
know flowery language that obviously
everybody agrees with
but what the defense is doing very
appropriately if you're representing
miss potter officer potter is you're
essentially saying she made a mistake
pulling out the gun not the taser but
given all of the circumstances
that he had an outstanding arrest
warrant
even if she intended to use the firearm
they're making an argument that she had
a right to shoot him because he was
trying to drive away and could have
caused the harm or death of a fellow
officer
it's it's actually
the best argument they can possibly make
whether a jury buys that is another
matter yeah i'll wait and see uh terry
uh bifurcated or or
or bifurcated i guess or unitary trial
and blakely issues were argued today can
you break those down for us
okay so under the blakely case a judge
cannot enhance a sentence
based on facts that aren't you know
tried by the jury or the defendant
agrees but the issue here is can those
be tried in a unified case or can they
be bifurcated and done separately if
there's a conviction the state said
there was an agreement to do it together
the defense said no way the judge said
we're going to separate it if there's a
conviction we'll do it after the trial
the one thing that the state got was
potter did on the record say she waved
her right to a jury but it's going to be
done after the trial all right so we'll
see how that second part if she's
convicted uh operates it's similar to
that of how derek showman had his trial
for those aggravating factors that the
prosecution put forward
thank you both we're also covering more
news out of minnesota as ex-officer and
convicted killer derek chovin is set to
change his plea in federal court on
wednesday our legal experts will explain
what that change could mean that's just
minutes ahead here on law and crime
daily still on still ahead on law and
crime daily bombshell text messages
released amidst the january 6
investigation what messages donald trump
jr sent mark meadows the day of the
attack
but first a massive settlement reached
for more than 500 larry nassar survivors
all that and more still ahead
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
monumental settlement is reached for the
survivors of lair nassar's sexual abuse
the amount 380 million dollars more than
500 girls and women were abused by
nassar the former u.s national
gymnastics team doctor among the victims
olympic gold medalist simone biles
michaela moroney and ali raisman the
survivors come into an agreement with
the usa gymnastics and the united states
olympic and paralympic committee this
settlement comes as usa gymnastics plans
to exit bankruptcy following years of
fallout from the nassar scandal and it's
separate from the 500 million dollar
settlement with a michigan state
university nassar is serving a 60-year
federal prison sentence on child
pornography charges he was also
sentenced in a state case from 40 to 175
years in september biles addressed the
abuse the u.s senate saying nassar and
the organizations involved should be
held accountable
i sit before you today to raise my voice
so that no little girl must endure what
i the athletes at this table
and the countless others who needlessly
suffered under nasser's guise
of medical treatment
which we continue to endure today we
suffered and continued to suffer because
no one at fbi usag or the usopc did what
was necessary to protect us
we have been failed and we deserve
answers
nassar is where he belongs but those who
enabled him deserve to be held
accountable
back to discuss this major settlement is
former federal prosecutor gene rossi and
terry austin terry the settlement
doesn't stop at just 380 million dollars
the olympic committees also have to make
safeguards so that this doesn't happen
again what could those be
you know i'll tell you the money is
important but not nearly as important as
these safeguards the judge agreed to the
settlement partially because of these
safeguards they made sure that the
athletes will be safe and that they will
be well and that everyone involved is
accountable one of the things they did
was dedicate seats on the board and also
in the committees to the survivors so
that is so they'll have some say in the
decisions going forward the other thing
they did brian is they made sure that
the training is better and that there
won't happen again
in this way and and finally the other
thing they did is they made sure that
reporting this type of misconduct can't
stop with one person there are different
levels and you are now required to
report what goes on and to take it up to
the next level so these are changes that
will help the girls in the future now
gene the olympia committee is being
penalized and forced to reform but to
miss bowel's point
what's going to happen to those who
turned a blind eye like the fbi
well they have egg on their face i don't
know if there are any criminal charges
there may be civil charges but it goes
to what terry just said about reporting
i cannot
imagine
that there were not
many multitudes hundreds of red flags
and loud gongs for those hundred to two
hundred uh young girls that were
assaulted i can't believe that that
there wasn't some signal that this guy
was up to no good and he was violating a
sacred trust with his patients yeah well
we'll continue to follow the story
hopefully we'll get more good news in
terms of reform and settlement so that
this is not something that the united
states gymnastics or any gymnastics
committee ever has to hear about again
thank you both switching now to
wisconsin where a 23 year old is accused
of kidnapping and killing his parents
faces a judge chandler halderson
appeared in dane county court on monday
just weeks before the start of his trial
prosecutors say halderson reported his
parents missing on july 7 after they
didn't return home from the fourth of
july weekend trip halderson was arrested
a day later when investigators found his
father's torso in a rural part of the
county days later his mother's remains
were found in a different county
investigators say halderson used his
google account to search terms like
body found wisconsin and wisconsin
dismembered body found before he
reported his parents missing halterson
is charged with multiple accounts
including first degree intentional
homicide mutilating a corpse and hiding
a corpse on monday a judge ruled both
sides must present information about
prospective jurors at the end of the
month jury selection is expected to
begin january third
coming up on law and crime daily derek
showman is set to change his plea to
guilty as the ex-police officer and
convicted killer faces federal charges
plus former trump chief of staff mark
meadows takes center stage in the
january 6 investigation all that and
more after the break
welcome back the so-called january 6
committee votes to recommend criminal
contempt charges against former trump
white house chief of staff mark meadows
on monday the committee revealed january
6 text messages sent to meadows from
donald trump jr and prominent fox news
urging staffers to get president trump
to condemn the attack this as a group
stormed the capital following the 2020
election the house select committee
formed an investigative and form to
investigate the riots voted on monday to
recommend medals be prosecuted for
criminal contempt of congress after
refusing to testify before the panel
meadows claims he doesn't have to
testify because of executive privilege
all this comes as the d.c attorney
general filed a lawsuit against dozens
of members of the proud boys and oath
keepers extremist groups calling their
actions on january 6 quote a coordinated
act of domestic terrorism
the executive privilege belongs to the
president of the united states has
president biden come in to invoke
executive privilege to stop mark meadows
from testifying about what took place on
january 6th
no he has not he is not right and has
former president trump mr chairman
um
has although he has no say in the matter
but has he even tried to come into the
committee to block the committee from
taking meadows testimony no
tuesday the house took the next step in
the process with a vote in the rules
committee that measure passed eight to
four it now moves to the full house for
a vote
let's bring back former federal
prosecutor gene rossi and co-host terry
austin to discuss the latest from the
january 6 committee terry the committee
is still collecting facts but so far do
you see any smoking guns
well brian as you mentioned it still has
to go to the full house before it even
reaches the doj i do think there are
some smoking guns listen there are
thousands and thousands of documents
apparently there are a thousand texts
just involving mark meadows and i think
it all depends on what did he know and
when did he know it and basically you
know he's being urged or he was at the
time to say something to donald trump
and the question is did he say something
or did he just ignore it so we'll have
to wait and see what happens and
basically we really need his testimony
but we aren't going to get it yeah gene
let's look even further ahead as terry
told us it's going to go to the full
house for a vote and then it goes to doj
if and when it gets the doj what's that
going to look like with these charges
oh he'll be charged with criminal
contempt this is a slam dunk there is
absolutely no defense that mark meadows
has you cannot just ignore the subpoena
you have to show up
he didn't even show up that per se is
contempt and if everybody did what mark
meadows did uh we'd never have
congressional oversight
it's gonna be interesting to see how
this plays out they're of course going
to try to enforce this as you're saying
gene so that others don't just skip out
when congress asks him to come and
testify
when we come back derek show been set to
appear in federal court with a change of
plea what a guilty plea could mean for
the ex-police officer and why he likely
made the change
welcome back to law and crime daily
court dates are pushed back for the
accused michigan high school shooter and
his parents as prosecutors sift through
a mountain of evidence on monday a judge
pushed back ethan crumbly's probable
cause hearing to january 7 after
prosecutors requested more time to
examine hundreds of pages of evidence
crumbly faces several charges in
connection to the november school
shooting in oxford michigan four people
were killed and seven others injured at
the hearing crumbly's attorneys asked
that he be transferred to the children's
village that houses juveniles the judge
denied the request ruling crumbly will
continue to be held at the oakland
county jail on tuesday oakland county
prosecutor karen mcdonald requested more
discovery time in the case of james and
jennifer crumbling the parents of the
alleged gunman prosecutors say their
case has so much evidence that there has
not been enough time to work through all
of it their hearing has also been
rescheduled to next year the couple is
charged with involuntary manslaughter
for which they each face up to 60 years
behind bars
former minneapolis police officer derek
shovin is expected to plead guilty in
federal court on wednesday morning in
connection to the death of george floyd
chopin is serving 22 and a half years
sentence after being convicted earlier
this year of second and third degree
murder and second degree manslaughter in
floyd's death a federal grand jury
indicted chauvin and three other
officers a short time later accusing
them of violating floyd's civil rights
shogun said at a sentencing in june that
he couldn't make a statement because of
other legal matters but alluded to a
possible plea deal
i
do want to give my condolences to the
floyd family
there's going to be some other
information
in the future that would be of interest
and
i hope things will give you some
some peace of mind
chopin is also accused of violating the
civil rights of a 14 year old boy during
an arrest in 2017. it does not appear
that he is changing his plea in that
case
jean experts have suggested that chauvin
is looking to plead uh guilty into the
federal charges ass at that time run
concurrent to the state time and then
serve his time in federal prison is that
possible and how
it's possible you've got to put a rope
through a needle because you have to
have the agreement of all the
prosecutors
state and federal have to have an
agreement of the state judge that once
he's sentenced he goes to federal prison
because it is a huge benefit
federal prisons are much better than
state prisons i don't care where you are
the other thing i'm interested in is he
gonna is he gonna cooperate
and provide uh inculpatory evidence
against his three co-defendants as a
result of this plea that's something i
want to see either in the plea documents
or if it's an oral agreement
we have to wait and see yeah and of
course the difference
especially with federal and state
charges in minnesota uh in federal
charges you do 85 percent of the
sentence so if you're charged with 10
years it's eight and a half years uh but
chovin's only going to do two-thirds of
that 22 and a half so they're going to
have to do a little bit of math there
much better than the math that i could
probably do but tara let's move away
from the math and let's talk about
something else at the sentencing of the
state case as we saw showing said that
we would hear something more later what
do you think he'll say
i do think he's going to express some
remorse i think he's going to also try
to explain his actions remember the
federal court case has two federal
charges against him they're saying that
he violated the constitutional right of
mr floyd by using one unreasonable force
and that he acted with deliberate
indifference and i do think even though
the case is very strong against sheldon
i do think he is going to try if he
pleads guilty to explain he wasn't using
unreasonable force at least briefly and
i think he's going to try to explain to
the family and to the whole world that
he does not have indifference he did not
you know express indifference he just
thought that that was the thing to do at
that time so we'll see what happens all
right a lot of potential out there for
what he could be saying on a wednesday
and of course we'll bring it to you when
we get it thank you both and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you